from Ukraine to religious tolerance
changing time to tea tip fire Europe's
forests a rich array of topics awake
sending peas during the coming week of
committee meetings and mini plenary
session in Brussels on Monday Mario
Draghi the chairman of the recently
rehoused european central bank will be
defending its new policy on quantitative
easing trillion euro plus ECB government
bond-buying scheme to stimulate the
eurozone economy that's what the
economic affairs committee the following
day a special discussion is to be held
in Parliament on the rise of religious
radicalism and fundamentalism in Europe
and how through inter-religious dialogue
to promote tolerance and dignity
Christian Muslim and Jewish leaders will
be in Parliament for this coming up in
the mini plenary on Wednesday a debate
on the European neighbourhood policy
following the launch of a review earlier
this month spotlight on the e used
future relations with 16 of its closest
neighbors from Morocco to Azerbaijan
fire Palestine Ukraine and Georgia the
last review was in 2011 since when have
been dramatic and violent developments
in many of the sixteen loveliest in
Ukraine the same day mep s will also be
voting on a 1.8 billion euro assistance
package to ukraine the union's largest
single a dispersal on Tuesday the
Agriculture Committee discusses its
response to European Commission
proposals for a new strategy on forests
replacing one dating back almost 20
years demand for logging and other
forest services will be on the agenda
along with their valuable social and
environmental grow and so what else as
the negotiations on the big eu-us trade
deal q-tip gather momentum though the
inputs from various committees during
the course of Google plenty to be
expected on the deals more contentious
elements will also be discussion with
the Commission
mini plenary on Wednesday on tax
transparency this just after parliament
launched a special committee to
investigate certain member states tax
rulings favorable to multinationals now
what time is it no no no no no hang on
what time should it be or could it be
are you like me more than a little
confused when it comes to Europe's
daylight saving summer time changes when
it's not summer yet when it's
technically of spring but it feels like
winter well we're in good company that's
it for the week in Brussels whatever
you're doing wherever and whenever try
not to be late and try not to be early
either